welcome to this video this is coverage
for game 11 of the World Championship
match between Magnus karsland vishy
anand yeah game 11 we're nearing the end
of the match and Carlton is still
leading this thing before game 11 and
Allen badly needs to win a game this one
game 11 with black on the final game
Liam 12 with white yeah a win but with
black hmm very difficult it was some
interesting to see what opening we will
see today yay accountant opened with
1.e4 as expected he played this the
whole match and had a entry good results
he 11 Berlin yeah the game game number
two and he won game 6 there by now
famous double blunder game but look this
the single spot was shaky in game 6 of
course but other than that it was a
convincing victory in a way as he had
the big opening advantage and then
converted this yeah so e4 again and
Allen is playing 'if I've so we will see
ruin ok and this basically means the
Berlin if you start with e 5 on that
level in the first place in this
situation it's clear that we would see
them the Berlin and not some complicated
closed we wear black ism yeah solid yeah
but if you I mean you're either a solid
here with black are you doing something
more ambitious and if it if ambitious
was the name of the game you probably
don't start with this in the first place
but go with a Sicilian or something more
offbeat but ok Allen has one white game
left in game 12 so he's probably figured
that being solid is the way to go so we
get the endgame as we already did in in
the very down game 9 and Game seven Game
seven was this marathon game the 120
move game and game 9 was the shore draw
yeah this time we get something a little
bit
and age 3 is played and our Bishop d7
this is one possible setup for black one
of many and this is a variation that
Ireland has not played yet with the
Bishop to d7 blacks idea is exactly what
happens in the game we can put this on
the board aged six kings ii eight and
now we went with c5 and b6 this is the
general setup that is initiated with the
move Bishop to d7 black puts the King to
c8 later intending to go King b7 and
finally connect the rooks if Black gets
to connect his rooks in the Berlin
endgame very often he is very close to
an equal game if he improves his
coordination he has the two bishops in
the long run and his structures not that
terrible very often the coordination is
the issue and we see that in this game
after rook fv1 Bishop 695 and now the
interesting moved g5 black am I think
soft is opening problems quite
convincingly we see that with g5 Black
is gaining quite some space on the Kings
side and what he does is he controls
crucial squares those kind of squares
that also makes it difficult for white
to get his three against therefore again
three majority on the kingside rolling
the drawback of the g5 move of causes
that this is really glaring weakness now
and also a square that will be used by
white in the future c4 very logical
mafia is support this night King be
seven and now King edge to this is a
move that could could have been expected
what white wants to do is play g4 and
possibly King g3 yeah gaining space on
the King side ultimately it's about
using this majority
really no other big plans here in the
structure black went 85 and this is now
prompting a standard response from white
white after a five he really has to play
a for this is a totally mandatory move
if you allow black to play a form you
simply give away um yeah all hopes of an
advantage and they're probably worse um
so let's say you play a nothing move
just to show the point then a form and
will accomplish an activation of this
rook and also a pawn coming to be three
I mean okay this is not a very
constructive move I just want to show
the general idea the b3 porn will be
weak and it's relatively easy to attack
sometimes you know black can do this
this kind of thing or sometimes night
here to be three so there are ways to
attack the weakness and this is much
easier possible here than with the f are
being closed so after a five white
really has to play for and it was done
quickly by carlson now nitey seven yeah
ninety-seven intends to regroup the
night to g6 then maybe Bishop e7 g4 was
played and Nagi six yeah g4 is a move
that is preparing king g3 and then
ultimately white wants to push f4 that's
really the only way forward in this
position otherwise you're just shuffling
pieces with no particular aim it's the
only way to really open up something
however the whole situation is in fact
far more complicated than it seems
because black has some very nice hidden
resources king g3 was played and we
should be seven finally yeah the rooks
now are connected
yeah and now this pollution here we can
start to really think about it a little
bit little bit more detail up to this
point it all went very very standard way
so what should white do now is it
possible to get an F for yeah this is
really the only player age form is
totally covered here by tons of pieces
so f form is really the only plan um
council is going for that the question
is however is that any good maybe Im he
should have chosen some some different
set up the way it went it had quickly
got to a situation where black was
feeling rather comfortable he played the
move for me Carson plate 92 now this is
a very logical choice you want to move
the f porn ultimately so you have to
move the night the question is where to
in the game Carlton went here yeah you
went to f6 the question is if this is
really really any good there are
alternatives white can also try
something like night f1 maybe intending
93 to f5 that was a possible alternative
I still think that like is some in the
fairly decent shape he has solved many
of his problems rooks are connected
those those breakthroughs on the
kingside are tough to achieve and there
are counter play ideas and the big
counter play idea we see in the game
after this 94 mph Bishop f8 was played
and now nitey f6 I put this on the board
earlier yeah this night it had a long
journey all the way to have six like
here and then to f6 what exactly is the
night doing there yeah what white wants
to do ideally is to play night age five
akia and then push air for
the D 59 and the age 59 they both
protect their four square so that f4 can
finally be achieved even if F form is
happening it's not so clear than it is
so terrible for white or black by the
way however in this position here black
in fact has an amazing a really amazing
um resource and I've now played the
really surprising move b5 this came is a
little bit of a shock I guess to too
many spectators and maybe also to to
Carlton it's really surprising right
black plays b5 putting this pawn on a
square where it is protected two times
yeah white can now take the pawn let's
have a look in fact one of the capture
see takes b5 can be very quickly
discarded because c6 is very strong the
night now is attacked on d5 if it goes
away this is falling and with it
basically the whole position white soul
position is falling apart as it now
opens up and blacks bishop pair gets
very very strong also there are many
possibilities like night f4 and and
other ways to use the holes in whites
position so the capture is totally
unplayable and then night s III I mean
if white then takes just to look at this
black recaptures and now we see the d5
is hanging so the night cannot be kept
on d5 again and after a move of the
night again b3 is going away and black
it enjoys a fantastic advantage again
note that this is a passer already and
it sometimes it's really supported by
the King the king is playing a good
active role here it's not a passive
spectator or week peace means that
taking with a see porn was completely
impossible
what about 80 x b5 this is a somewhat
better choice and could be considered
however after a form takes rook takes we
see all of a sudden how this rook is
gone active from a form it takes c4 and
wide really cannot allow black to get
this pawn if the c-4 porn is falling b5
this is the next weakness and again
blacks position that suddenly is the
science you open up we'll have good use
for the bishop am very nice position for
black yeah rook c1 probably have to
continue this line it is necessary to to
keep them keep this protected and after
that black in fact has more than one
interesting try one one possible way to
play which is not the only one is the
night air form yeah putting enormous
pressure here and also 93's in the mix
yeah if white takes it something like
that might happen and black gets active
we are really really active so many many
opportunities there for black to seize
the initiative it seems that the
captures on b5 are both bad ctx p5 is
really really bad and 8x b5 looks dodgy
means that okay black just could play b5
and white really cannot take it so
cousin after I think I'm being a little
bit stunned for a moment it seems played
bishops III yeah this is a waiting move
in a way but it also does something
positive it puts the bishop away from
the B file that's about to be opened we
can put this on the board like traded so
the B file is open and it puts this
Bishop away from the beef are attacking
the a5 for now this is a good good thing
attacking this weakness yeah ana now
played king c6 a very logical move
activating the king and opening up the
beef
clearing the beef out for the rooks ya
can't invent king of three this is a
good move really the idea is that this
king should be used actively in the
proceedings and the White King will even
step up to e form supporting the d5
night yeah there's some pressure on this
night and the king will help to support
here we come to a total key position of
this game Allen now look more than 20
minutes for this move and he correctly
sensed that this is the the critical
situation black in fact has a number of
possibilities to consider mostly there
are two ideas I think um black can play
rook to be eight yeah rook d to be eight
intending to do something on the beaver
which is what are not ultimately played
but he also has other ideas and the
ideas are Bishop e7 and Bishop g7 I
think both are valid ideas the ideas
that the bishop on evade is not very
active at the moment and trading it
against the night might be very helpful
let's say after Bishop e7 there are some
interesting possibilities if white now
place Kingi form as was originally
planned I think that after Bishop f6e
takes f6 night xf6 is immediately
blundering this he takes f black might
just take here keeping it simple in a
way takes and king d 6 yeah and now we
see that the d5 pawn is probably just a
weakness looky 8 is coming and the white
king is not really helping much am black
seems to be in good shape here means
that probably after Bishop e7 the move
kini for isn't really good the idea to
take on f6 really is quite serious maybe
maybe why it has to
something like 93 yeah retreating not a
happy move not something that what yeah
what's was dreaming about I guess yeah
but after that is there something for
black to play for ya he can take f6 and
maybe play a position like that
something something along these lines
intending to invade yeah white can take
on a 5 but we will get a 4 and ce4 is a
little bit weak there's also night f4
it's possible that black here is
slightly better it it feels at least
easier to play for black mostly because
whites weaknesses here yeah potentially
see for a 4 they feel a little bit more
severe than whites when then then blacks
weaknesses like a five or c5 if white
for example takes and something like
that definitely black is the one
dictating events yeah I mean here after
something some covering move this even
this one and you will lose the pawn I
think this Bishop e7 move was a pretty
good opportunity for for black but it is
a very difficult position to judge he
went rogue db8 as mentioned now after
King e-form we have the second critical
situation here the move that on an
ultimately played was infected what I
had suggested and it seems that it's not
a really good move so I was suggesting
the right move in a way but but not the
right move um black hair played are now
played the interesting move look to be
for an exchange sacrifice this is a very
commonly known motive I even made a
video about it a while ago and at least
them for for similar situations what is
blacks idea with the move the idea is
that if white takes the rook and it is
basically necessary to
take it that his pawn structure will
improve he will get a pass to be pawn
and possibly win more points along the
way this is not a stupid idea rookie
before but it ultimately seems to be not
not totally sufficient alternatively
Anand could have played rugby 3 which
was of course the more conservative
choice and maybe this is the one that he
should have played it some probably
quite okay for black there are
interesting ideas yet it's not a totally
a simple or clear-cut position um after
rugby 3 for example rook be one black
has an interesting idea here that I was
discussing during the broadcast already
rook a 3 rook a 1 and black maybe can
take on c3 him a different type of pawn
sacrifice an exchange sacrifice I'm
sorry Black has a pawn for the exchange
he has the complete bishop pair and he
has chances to play against this e5 pawn
one virtue of this g5 push earlier is
that it isolates this e5 pawn from the
rest of whites forces and means that if
I've can sometimes really be a liability
this in fact is a very interesting
position that is probably maybe about
equal but I mean everything can happen
here would have been very interesting to
see to see this position of being played
Black's plan amongst others is to play
Bishop here and then maybe even take on
e5 there are mating ideas sometimes
without the King takes rupee aid um yeah
this would have been interesting I think
rook to e3 is what he should have done
look before when I suggested this move I
was thinking that after Bishop takes
which has to be played I was thinking
that Alan's idea is to take with da pawn
and it was my idea at least and I was
thinking that okay if I get this pawn
and that can be active with Maruk then
black definitely has enough compensation
for the exchange at the moment I mean
the white looks are not doing that much
however I'm not sure that this is a
sufficient compensation as well one key
problem at least that's what I believe
is that black when he takes the a pawn
will be hit with roo k1 and we have a
rope trade to make it clearer if white
is doing something like this which makes
some sense yeah maybe prepare form and
black takes the pawn which hmm it's hard
to avoid in a way I mean if you don't
take this how are you continuing then
rugae one is coming and rook trade now
is forced and without rooks it seems
difficult for black to claim a
sufficient compensation also note that
white immediately and tends to invade on
the a foul that's probably not enough
and if ya if you don't take on a
four-year what is your move it's it's
very very difficult I mean it's not like
white has an easy way for but if black
is playing a slow move but it's not
really the point of this exchange sec
yeah well after this unsurprisingly took
with the sea porn which I didn't expect
her to happen at all and it ultimately
seems that it is not enough after night
h5 now which is strong but still rather
obvious why doesn't ending to play a 4
as it was all along this King only for
really plays a useful role it supports
the five it supports f4 very nice yeah
after night age five it seems that black
has a hard time he played King to be
seven intending to push away in the
night with c6 however after F form the
problem is that the move c6 is not
leading to anything as white can just
push with that five
something like see takes see takes just
wins for white very easily yeah we have
yeah I mean tons of forks and we'll win
back one piece and still retain a
fantastic pawn roller in the center so
c6 is not possible at all and if that's
not possible what are you doing there f5
is a big threat so there is really not
much than taking on air form there's
this suggestion that has been made on to
try to improve it might be better but
still after f5 Bishop takes a form takes
on g 6 and 10 cm ultimately this is not
sufficient yeah here black would be a
piece down after he regains the exchange
and the thing is that this a pawn is
also very very strong so this is not
sufficient as well ya allah took on a
form at the end Knight takes Knight
takes Knight takes yeah now what cards
and places is total precision here black
has a hard time fighting this Knight
takes c6 move you basically have to take
on c4 there is nothing else yeah and now
the key move is the following rook to d7
yeah with this maneuver the rook is
activated very nicely and yeah what
exactly can black try to do it's very
difficult to find any any defense iam
and I mean not only difficult there is
there is no defense to be honest he
tried Rooke a 6 here all I did
alternatively you can look at other
moves like maybe King c6 but then why
does retreating and coming up with Luke
see one next yeah something like this
for example
this will be winning rook c8 and then
ultimately 95 with c7 collapsing the
only thing that why it always has to
watch out for is that there isn't some
some silly trick with the beep on but
it's really nothing nothing serious if
you are precise so King c6 wouldn't have
helped as well rook a6 was played and
now 95 yeah that sets again important to
be to be this precise if you play
instead the move Roxy one for example
then something like b3 my turn well
let's say sorry rook c6 first of course
Roxy six and then be three might prove
to be very tricky all of a son but 95 is
is just stronger yeah rook csis 16 plate
plate and just rook takes f7 gaining a
tempo on this Bishop and Bishop c5 yeah
um around here there's more than one way
to to decide decide the game but
Countians is probably the most forceful
he played rook takes his seven just
giving away this the point is that if
black is taking the night now there is
the move rook c1 and well you lose one
of those bishops back this is not
helping because it's a check and then
Ruby 5 p-2 will pick up the beep on so
after night c7 teensy 7 cannot really be
played and this meant that King z6
happened yeah now night b5 just back
securing the night here i think carlton
calculated this till the end it's not
that difficult black took him king sorry
ecigs first beer three king III and
this pawn is very very dangerous of
course we should be seven and now the
decides deciding touch is h4 there were
other moves but h4 is the is the
cleanest a 4g five takes takes a three
this was played if black takes on g5
then e7 is just easily winning as widest
it's just about quick enough to stop all
the pawns yeah like let's say look rook
a 7 or what is the quickest em yeah many
many ways to win really many ways you
can for instance also do this something
something like that oh I'm sorry that's
it that's it that's in fact screwing it
up so not root b 7 what is the easiest
hear me okay just just go here and block
the whole thing not making things too
difficult okay in the game Allen played
a 3 still and after King c3 he resigned
the game and this was the end of the
match cards and won the match with this
victory in game 11 and 4 total score of
six and a half versus four and a half
for the Challenger so in this game the
match was was ultimately decided one
game before game 12 so there wasn't a
final there won't be a final game the
day after tomorrow on Tuesday yeah what
to make of this game it was a very
interesting game I believe and this is
largely due to the fact that when we
jump back that this b5 resource was all
of a sudden popping up surprisingly
really surprisingly it really looked
like the queenside is almost frozen but
it didn't happen with b5 all of the
sudden there was an opening of the
position and it really looked like um
black was
taking over the initiative and it
probably really is the case that after
King f3 there are continuations that are
more comfortable for black it does not
seem to be something totally a decisive
or or yeah I mean you cannot prove a
clear advantage is what I'm trying to
say for black but he definitely had the
initiative here and it seems at least
this is what I gathered from quotes of
the press conference that wishy maybe
got a little bit too too yeah optimistic
about the whole procedure and he got
this idea with rook v8 to before and
went for it a little bit too yeah maybe
a little bit 22 22 optimistically and
spontaneously in a way it can happen it
definitely can happen especially if you
feel like this is this is your moment
where you need to go for idea and I
totally understand understand the idea i
mean at the same idea it just seems to
not be not be that great um yeah other
ways but maybe more interesting as we
are not interesting but promising let's
say interesting it was but it didn't
didn't really seem to work out maybe
here this is what he should have tried i
think in comparison that that this this
kind of exchange sacrifice was was
really interesting or Bishop e7 earlier
this is the these are the key moments of
this game but you also have to give
credit to Carson when it came to
converting the whole thing he was
playing absolutely perfectly um somehow
he got into this situation with b5 and
this is really a resource that you can
easily overlook and he really defended
perfectly after that it's an i mean it's
it's not his his problem if are not
displaying moves like Luke before and
she takes before you just played played
excellently well after that he somehow
got into this trouble yeah with b5 but
he once he was there he
is really giving us his very best so at
the end a match victory for the world
champion who was the favored beforehand
um if we look at the the overall cause
of the match I think that it was
probably probably about what we could
expect I mean I expected Carlton to win
this match she was the favorite but I
thought that it should be a somewhat
close affair than the last time and it
really was i mean it is it is one thing
to look at this game where are not had
some opportunities but also don't forget
Game six game six really could have led
to a totally different match if on and
just at this particular moment sees that
kinky too is a huge blunder and wins
this game then this is getting to a
totally different conclusion this match
and this also would have meant that ant
leads yeah and this is the first time
that Carson actually is behind in a
world championship match and this is a
totally different story yeah you never
know how stable people are under under
this huge pressure and yeah this is
maybe well well this is certainly a key
point of this match this game six but
it's still it could have gone gone both
ways if aren't is playing better here in
them in the critical in the critical
positions yeah okay i hope you enjoyed
the match i think most games were
interesting and i also hope that you
enjoyed the coverage that i am that i
provided i think that the next big event
that will get some coverage is probably
why kinzey in in january i'm not totally
sure about the tournament calendar but i
think there is nothing so exciting that
that
should be covered but okay if I see
something I might might do that also I
want to take this opportunity and thank
the many spectators and fans of the
channel who donated to the course it
really helps to keep this this channel
going simply because i mean i have
invest quite a lot of time into it and
if I don't at least a little bit of
money with it it's it's hard to maintain
in the long run so thanks a lot for all
the support and also for the nice nice
comments that that the day that I get
often alright thanks for watching this
and one thing i can add that then the
next live stream of blitz chess by the
way is happening on monday the 24th i
will also put a video out of course to
to announce it again so thanks for
watching this and i'll be back soon with
new content thanks